this and I am in good company or joined
by three scientists who have been
studying how to build computers based on
ideas that Einstein once called spooky
computers that are orders of magnitude
faster and more powerful than today's
most souped-up supercomputers and I am
no Einstein but I have watched enough
Star Trek to know that we are talking
about quantum computing without which
the Starship Enterprise would never have
reached those distant galaxies or so I'm
to believe
please welcome three of the intrepid
explorers who might help us someday get
to Cardassia prime Scott Aaronson
associate professor of electrical
engineering and computer science at MIT
Mattias trier professor of computational
physics at ETH Zurich and Krista savoir
a manager of the quantum architectures
and computation group at Microsoft
Research Redmond you guys got some
titles congratulations well thanks for
being here Krista I want to start with
you asking you to explain what a quantum
computer is and how it's different from
today's conventional computers it sounds
cool
if it's cool yeah quantum computer is a
next generation computing device that
we're working on building now our
colleagues and the community is working
on and it revolves around quantum
mechanics so it's based on quantum
mechanics instead of classical mechanics
so instead of just bits of information
you have quantum bits of information and
these bits are you know really special
and that now you can take instead of
just a classical bit which is a 0 or a 1
value you actually can take a
superposition that means it's
simultaneously and the zero value and
the 1 value at the same time so you can
imagine that this might give you some
speed ups because of the parallelism you
can compute on multiple values at the
same time so this is you know one piece
so superposition and entanglement are
key pieces to the quantum computer that
we try to take advantage of when we
design problems that will we hope to
solve with it ok so I gotta go to my
cheat sheet here a quantum computer is
basically it would build transistors
that could function in accordance with
the quantum principles yeah that's right
so we and it'll be a hybrid device that
has a classical controller a classical
computer that's controlling the quantum
computer and then once you go into the
quantum state
you do a bunch of operations but it's
clone and we can't look at it if we look
at it it's like Schrodinger's cat it's
dead and alive at the same time until
you open the box and then it's dead or
alive right you've measured the state
and collapsed it back to a classical
system so this quantum computing what
happens is we initialize the kalam state
we send it through a bunch of quantum
operations and then at the end we can
actually look inside the box and measure
the system and we get back classical
information this is also why it's hard
to design problems for a quantum
computer because you you have to keep it
isolated you're not allowed to look at
it while you're doing the computation at
the end you can measure it and see I see
a result it'll collapse to one of the
states it doesn't remain in the
superposition at the end okay so I know
for you guys this is your area of
expertise but for some of the folks
watching and certainly for me bring us
inside Scott what makes a qubit
different from a regular bit okay well
it's impossible to answer the question
without saying a little bit about I
believe in you about about quantum
mechanics so you know now quantum
mechanics has this reputation for being
complicated and hard we the secret is
it's actually incredibly simple once you
take the physics out of it okay so the
the key I think is the to this concept
of superposition that Krista was just
talking about right you might say well
you know to say that the bid is both 0
and 1 at the same time right as you know
people always say you know isn't that
just a fancy way of saying that it's
either 0 or 1 and we just don't know
which and then you know you look at it
and you see it's either a 0 or a 1 and
now you know all right what's so magical
about that ok the key is that quantum
mechanics such as this you know
revolution in physics 100 years ago
sort of replaced the rules of
probability that we have to use by some
new much more counterintuitive rules
right so normally you know you might say
there's a 30% or 50% chance of rain
tomorrow you'd never say there's a
negative 30% chance right that's just
stupid
ok but with quantum mechanics you have
to talk you have to talk about numbers
called amplitudes instead of
probabilities amplitudes can be positive
or negative in fact they can even be
imaginary numbers ok but now to you know
now the rule is to find the probability
that something is going to happen like
your computer is going to
give a particular answer when you look
at it you have to add up the amplitudes
for all of the different ways that this
could happen okay and then you square
the result okay but the result of this
is that if if something could happen one
way with a positive amplitude and
another way with a negative amplitude
those two ways could cancel each other
out so that the event never happens at
all okay and so qubits are bits that can
exploit this principle of it's called
quantum interference okay and it's sort
of the secret behind anything anyone
ever tells you about the spookiness of
the quantum world right it's all based
on this this one little trick of
interference over and over and in
particular a quantum computer would be a
computer that uses this interference
effect in order to try to choreograph
things so that you know for each
possible wrong answer you know some of
the paths leading there have positive
amplitude others have negative amplitude
so they cancel each other out whereas
the paths that lead to a right answer
should have amplitudes that reinforce
each other okay so it's a very
specialized kind of thing you know
quantum computing is not a panacea that
you know it's going to let us solve
every problem faster there are some
problems where a classical computer
looks just as good okay but you know for
certain special problems like finding
the factors of enormous numbers you know
people have discovered remarkable ways
to sort of exploit this magic of
interference to solve it using a quantum
computer much much faster than we know
how to solve it with any existing
computer well I love how you just make
it sound so matter-of-fact the kinds of
things that I would see as a kid in a
movie and go oh come on there's no way
well it's fascinating stuff yeah well
you want me to tell it like it is or not
like it don't sugarcoat it so with all
this speed quantum computer could
quickly compute the algorithm needed for
deep space travel but let's go back to
kid movies leaving science fiction aside
for a minute what sort of things might a
quantum computer do that today's
conventional computers can't okay so yes
I think the most fascinating thing is
that it can actually solve the equations
of quantum mechanics so is this so
quantum Europe the mechanic is weird
it's difficult for
the classical machine and and I still
want to solve the equations because I
want to make a quantum your tips its
material with special properties in
superconducting you one device but in
order to design it I have to solve the
equation of quantum mechanics and a
classical computer that's hard and so
the big breakthrough there would be to
just use quantum mechanics to solve the
equations of near quantum mechanics and
that's what we could do to build the
data then negative 13y a the computer
that helps me find nu- the
superconductor that that would be
superconducting may be at room
temperature and then with happening us
did differ it have their transport of
electric power test without loss or we
find the and do you only get that it's
catalyst for turning negative thinking
at the nitrogen in to to negative
fertilizer or we could fall look for
gonna get catalyst turning a co2 into
the tourniquet that carbonates so kind
of hard quantum chemistry question hard
upon the physics questions that we could
solve with it and that would help us
name alright let's talk about some of
the other areas like improving
encryption obviously the beneficial
everybody uses their credit cards to
purchase stuff we all do it most most of
us everyday even I can relate are there
other areas where quantum computers
might be useful I mean obviously it
seems like a lot of other areas so
improve you said improving encryption
them famous application of quantum
computers is breaking encryption
breaking you know most of the
caption that people use the day to
protect their credit card numbers which
you know makes you know certain
three-letter government agencies you
know very interested in this field but
you know you could say maybe you know
that that's not really sustainable
application right people will just it
just means that when quantum computers
become practical people have to switch
to other cryptographic codes that are
that are more secure against quantum
attack but you know so besides a quantum
simulation which matthias mentioned in
which i think is a huge application area
maybe the most important one in practice
if we ever get quantum computers and
cryptanalysis which sort of makes the
headlines for obvious reasons I think
there's a third very important one which
is a you know trying to solve
optimization problems like scheduling
airline flights things of that nature
now for these problems it's important to
say we don't really know how much
advantage you're going to get with a
quantum computer you know you may get a
modest advantage you know you maybe
you'll get a larger one for the
cryptanalysis and the quantum simulation
we're very confident that you'll get a
huge advantage so I mean is it possible
or not to think that quantum computers
will replace traditional computers well
my future surface will this be full of
qubits you know you don't you don't need
a quantum computer for playing Angry
Birds or for checking your email I think
of the possibilities yeah all right I
mean I mean people you know it made me
right I mean the counter-argument would
be people said back and then you know
1950s well you know computers are great
for science but you know no one is ever
gonna need one in their home right so
maybe in a hundred years from now people
will be playing quantum video games and
they'll be doing all kinds of things
that we can't even imagine today right
all I can say is that as far as we can
see today this looks like a computer
that would really push forward the
boundaries of what we can do for certain
specialized problems scientific problems
right at home you might as well just
have a classical computer and you know
dial into the quantum computer you know
like as part of a cloud well when you
need it for something right in general
quantum computers now have to be you
know most most of the devices have to be
very cold so they sit in a huge dilution
refrigerator you know as tall as you
know this panel just could say the name
even I think it's in some remote forest
in this giant building Morris
yeah believers it's it's kind of like
that it's a huge refrigerator with a lot
of graduate students and postdocs
walking around plugging things in lower
things is that bubbly smoke coming out
of it
so I mean obviously there's
special-purpose devices but you know
quantum computers obviously what kind of
be game changers you know you it does
make me wonder how close you are to
making a workable quantum computer in
time for Christmas well so quantum
computer has been built which is
factored 15 into 3 times 5 with very
high statistical confidence and I've
even 21 equals 3 times 7 has been done
so we have some computers at work
yeah yeah very very small very small we
need you know millions of qubits to do
something interesting maybe in time
we'll come up with algorithms that use
you know 10,000 qubits and do something
interesting but right now the size of
these systems are maybe fourteen qubits
so if we need millions were a ways away
but we hope that in particular at
Microsoft we study something called
topological qubits or topological
quantum computation and we hope there
that the scaling once we have qubits in
that system the scaling will be quite
easy and we can reach the millions in a
more you know in way than reaching the
millions required in other devices other
quantum devices so we're looking at this
you know from many different directions
hoping that the scaling will will happen
in the next maybe ten years mm-hmm
this is obviously just just a surface
it's not a quantum computer but I can
get emails on here and actually somebody
just sent us a message somebody watching
online a Scott they've directed it right
at you our np-hard problems still
np-hard with quantum computing or more
generally how will the complexity theory
as we know change np-hard problems so I
should clarify this is a famous class of
of hard problems that you know can where
where you can sort of take problems like
the Traveling Salesman problem and map
them onto these problems that's what it
means for them to be np-hard and
absolutely the answer is yes np-hard
problems are still
you know np-hard it's just a
mathematical concept right that doesn't
even depend on physics okay but you know
one of the the basic questions that
people ask you know when the ideas of
quantum computing first started you know
getting explored maybe 20 years ago was
could a quantum computer give you a fast
way to solve these np-complete problems
okay so you know I met as I mentioned
earlier there was this remarkable
quantum algorithm for factoring numbers
and thereby for breaking much of the
cryptography that we use that's based on
you know the belief that that problem is
hard you know there's also algorithms
for quantum simulation that matthias
mentioned okay but you know both of
those are fairly specialized tasks right
and a real Holy Grail would be if you
could find a fast quantum algorithm for
these np-complete problems because this
is you know encompasses actually tens of
thousands of different practical
problems all fall into this class and
you know many popular articles actually
give the the misperception that a
quantum computer could do these just by
trying every possible answer in parallel
somehow right now the problem with that
is that you know as Krishna mentioned at
some point you've got to look at the
computer and when you look at it you
just get a single random answer right if
you just wanted that then you know you
could have picked one yourself with much
less trouble okay no need for the giant
dilution refrigerator right so you know
any hope for getting a quantum speed-up
relies on the magic of this interference
effect and unfortunately after decades
of research we do not know how to use
interference to get sort of an
exponential speed-up over a classical
computer for solving these np-complete
problems okay in special cases you you
may get an exponential speed-up and you
may get sort of a more modest speed up
you know in general we're not really
sure you know it would help if we had a
quantum computer to test things out with
right but so so the the bottom line is
that quantum computing you know does
change you know our picture of
complexity theory and some very
interesting ways it pushes forward you
know you might have thought that you
could figure out a priori sitting in
your armchair you know what is the right
definition of an efficiently computable
quantum computing
and says no you know the laws of physics
change that you might have thought that
factoring was you know a hard problem
but you know if you have a quantum
computer than it isn't okay but on the
other hand for these np-complete
problems you know not even a quantum
computer seems to help so even with a
quantum computer there seem to be very
important limits to what you can do
there is a buzzword that has popped up
entanglement we have not heard it
mentioned yet
oh she mentioned it yes the people want
to know we got a question they came in
about it
circle back people want to know about
that well entanglement is essentially
the spooky action at a distance
principle where we can entangle two
qubits and then we can separate them you
know far far apart and if I act on this
qubit it is also acting on this qubit
these qubits are entangled you know a
bell pair or an EPR pair is an entangled
state and you separate them you know
arbitrarily long distance and whenever I
do something here it actually also
occurs here or it affects here well
we're running short on time here and
this is a very complex thing a couple
things I want to know number one which
I've sort of already tried to get out of
you when do you suspect you could see a
viable quantum computer prototypes are
out there but it took more than a
hundred years from Charles Babbage until
the invention of the transistor I think
that if we can beat that then we're
doing pretty well I don't have that much
time yeah well unfortunately or the
problem is that sort of you know science
doesn't move in media speed all right
this is a this is the fundamental
problem here right and people always
want to know how many qubits do you have
so far right and you know I think that
most of the scientists are focused on
just getting two or three qubits that
you know that really work right and you
know we don't yet have sort of the
quantum computing version of the
transistor right the basic building
blocks to scale up you know where we're
working on that but you know many times
like heavier-than-air flight right
people realize that something seems
compatible with the laws of physics you
know and it could be hundreds of years
before the engineering catches up to
that now I hope that in twenty or thirty
years you know in this case that maybe
you know we'll start seeing if not full
quantum computers then at least ones
that can really outperform classical
computers you know in a fair come
Harrison you know and in fact there
there's a company that's been making
claims to have these computers now that
remains highly disputed okay but uh you
know it's it's you it's easy to see you
know or you know you could build a
device you know it can use quantum
mechanics but then you know you know I
mean everything involves quantum
mechanics at a small enough scale right
but then the real question is are you
actually doing something faster than you
could do it with our existing computers
right and I think you know maybe you
know hopefully in twenty or thirty years
we'll be able to sort of at least for
some maybe some special purpose problem
that you know has no application so that
no one cares about but at least show
that we could do something faster than a
classical computer could do it yeah
bonus points are getting it done in the
next fifty years while I'm around
alright well I'll tell the
experimentalist to get working on it
harder is put in a note of course we're
going to have a quantum computer here in
the studio we could have used to suspend
time but not so we must march on we have
run at a time thanks to my guest Krista
Matias Scott thank you guys a rather
mind swelling discussion there thank you
guys thank you much